[Music]
[Applause]
luno the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin if you're just getting into
crypto it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the lay
high or pan show as usual it's powered
by icon plus capital so they're a vc
firm and it is sponsored by block five
so with block five you can get really
cool interest rates um i think it's
pretty important given interest rates
are practically zero and if you're
unfortunate enough to live across europe
they're actually negative interest rates
so pretty pretty rubbish so you'll see a
link somewhere and everywhere um if
you're interested now joining me today
is a good friend of mine somebody who i
actually interviewed when i first got
into the space so um he is somebody that
i that i've known for a while now and he
has a very
very interesting story it is of course
my good friend joel joel how you doing
i'm doing fantastic uh very honored to
be on again thanks again
yeah it's really good to chat to you um
like i was saying for those that don't
know you're one of the very first people
that i interviewed um back in was it
2018 when i first started working
professionally in this space
yeah i think it was how are you right
i'm doing fantastic i mean you know the
world gets crazier by the minute but in
a lot of good ways as well as bad ways
and i like to focus on those
yeah i think we are very aligned um when
it comes to the reason why we're in
crypto what we like about it um in terms
of freedom
and everything um but before we jump
into all of that you have a super unique
story it's so interesting
um
like i said when i did the show with you
i did it because we only spoke to people
who had these really weird and quirky
things going on so for those that don't
know please just tell us your story john
yeah so the bullet point of that is i've
been living unbanked off of crypto for a
little over five years now
so that's the short of it and pretty
much the longer of it is
basically i became interested in you
know precious metals and sound money and
things with the whole you know
before the ron paul revolution in
american politics but also during and
i was kind of frustrated at how everyone
talks about
how the money how fiat currency is
essentially you know robbing from people
and funding all these kinds of terrible
things but then no one was doing
anything about it other than talking
about it like how could you say oh yeah
this is terrible by the way all i have
is fiat it just did not make sense i was
trying to live off of not fiat and you
couldn't really do that off of gold even
though i was trying with a you know one
of the peter schiff's
debit cards back in the day it was just
doing what i could but it didn't you
know it didn't really work out and then
someone i i shared a lunch with a friend
in chicago and
we had pizza and he paid for his part of
the pizza in bitcoin so i do have a
bitcoin pizza origin story
and okay so that's how i got started
with bitcoin
and then started using it you know for
the for the next couple of years and
then around about the end of 2015 i just
decided you know what i'm too excited
about this stuff
but i
i don't feel comfortable telling other
people hey this is awesome get into this
if i'm just sitting in the safety of my
own like little non like fiat world
saying you know so in order to be able
to you know basically not be not be full
of crap i decided to
only start living off of bitcoin and i
did that starting at the very end of
2015. somewhere about six months in i
closed my bank account as well and
started living unbanked
and then by the end of the year bitcoin
became less of an efficient means to
that end and so i started using dash
instead for you know my everyday money
and then you know fast forward today and
i'm still doing it
okay so just to let you know your
internet is coming in and out a bit so i
did just miss the end of what he said
but it's i got most of it um
so the crux of that essentially is that
you're living on banks you've been
totally living off of crypto since 2016
15 16. um i want to go back just a
second because you said that you had
this genuine just distaste towards the
fiat system and you know we often talk
about inflation and money printing and
and all the of these things but
it's it's hard really you know to
explain these things to the ordinary
person so what really um kind of woke
you up and made you realize you know
damn this system is actually
um
in some ways perhaps you know stealing
from me that's often how i how i look at
inflation anyway i look at it as theft
but
yeah well it i guess it comes back to
just education i was kind of i was home
schooled and so i come from a more
non-traditional educational background a
little more free thinking i guess but
still learning the history of money as
anyone any child when they're learning
like what is money
you have that education of like well you
know people used to trade with they used
to barter and then they used to trade
with these items and then they finally
found like precious rocks and metals and
then they turned those into coins and
then that's then eventually that became
inefficient these paper notes to
represent the
the actual money and then at some point
then there's just the paper notes and i
missed that like
what happened there like i followed the
story all the way up until the real
money's gone it just disappears and
we're going to just play pretend with
these like paper notes because that
would never have worked in the beginning
and
that always puzzled me but then also i
grew up in the north of mexico and right
after the peso crisis of the 90s and so
like my grandmother had a bunch of old
coins that just didn't work anymore and
no no those are the old ones these are
the new ones the new ones work and like
why do we have new ones oh the old one
the old currency just didn't work like
and so i always think like well that
could happen to the dollar too and i see
the exchange rate the one that i
memorized as a child was seven pesos to
the us dollar now i don't know what it
is today but it's got to be more than
like 28 or more and so i kind of have
that mental thing of oh this is not
this isn't just absolutely this isn't
god-given this is something that can
fluctuate in value but more importantly
just goes down over time and of course
when you start to become you know
i'm not that old but i'm old enough to
start remembering when things were
cheaper when everything was cheaper i
remember like if you had a 10 menu item
at a restaurant that was like super
fancy it had to have a bunch of seafood
in there or something yeah and then now
it's like a basic hamburger and a basic
whatever it can get them to that level
and it's probably gonna be it's not even
that in england i'll just tell you it's
not even that hard
yes i did um i did my post-graduate
university of buckingham right by oxford
right and so i remember those uk prices
it's pretty crazy
yeah so but i think you make a really
interesting point
sorry god i think there's a delay maybe
it's my internet go on sorry
yeah so you did that just
you know the kind of long and short of
it is basically i never had this
illusion that money was perfect and then
of course we start seeing about nearly
you learn about government and spending
and things like that and it's like okay
well this is much comes out of taxes
this much comes out of debt but they're
spending more than all that
and then oh they just print money you
hear about like what does that even mean
and then
i like once you once you basically have
an education on how the world actually
works with it doesn't have to be a tin
foil that crazy you know what they're
really doing they're messing up the
money you just have to have a basic
understanding that anyone who's educated
even who doesn't agree with but maybe we
would know
you just how do you reconcile those
things and just think oh you just make
fake money well then if you can just
make fake money to pay off things first
off why don't you print more money and
just buy everything like clearly they
know that there's some limits to this
thing and also if it is fake money
why are we using fake money you know
like if if they can just do this why are
we just sitting and taking it just
sitting and
living under a system that you know can
pretty much damage us and so
when i heard about you know the power of
cryptocurrencies specifically about
in you know first bitcoin and then
obviously later dash and plenty of other
ones i still
just the fact there's only ever going to
be 21 million and in order to change
that you'd have to basically get
everyone on board and even if the people
who weren't on board
you know they could still keep using a
version of the coin that they liked like
if most of bitcoin decided to just we're
gonna you know 10x the supply or
whatever and i didn't want that and like
a bunch of people like that we would
just fork off and be using
we'd still get to use the money we
wanted and just that that choice
is i mean it's revolutionary and i think
that's the underpinning of you know all
cryptocurrency all the value it creates
i mean we have a whole lot of different
projects there like infant inflation
rates or just huge supplies or
arbitrarily change supplies or things
like that i think people have lost the
plot just a little bit on like
that's not the reason we came to all
this sure you experiment with other fun
things sure maybe have a slow like for
example the way monero does a tail
emission or something a slow permanent
inflation but very small okay that's
fine experiment with those things but
just the sound money principles are kind
of why we're all really here if you
think about it
yeah i want to go back a sec because you
said something really interesting which
um
i really want to just echo for everyone
you spoke about your experience in
mexico and you sort of have these um
memories in your head of what prices
used to be
and you know you've seen over time what
has happened and i think it's only
experience which can really um help you
understand why we do what we do and i
think this kind of idea is the same in
politics like you often have um
you know people coming from um
previously authoritarian dictatorship
type countries coming over to let's say
the states and voting republican because
they understand you know what happened
basically um so i think that's really
really true and
for you with everything that's you know
all the problems in terms of inflation
and everything that you've described
which really kind of
put you off of the traditional system
and made you go entirely unbanked do you
feel that you've actually been able to
benefit in times of you know literally
leaving the system um i'm not gonna ask
you specifically um about taxes but you
know in terms of taxes in terms of
inflation in terms of being more
sovereign you know it's been how many
years
six years did you say six years five
years five five without a oh like five
in a couple months without a bank
account
so have you have you felt and seen a
direct benefit from that
um
so the
i would i definitely say yes it's a
little bit
the
i'm early to the process you know
especially because
you know back in the day
of 2015 2016 there wasn't a lot you
could really do with bitcoin you could
buy a few different things with it and
then
i was kind of early to the whole
you know scaling when the scaling wars
started with bitcoin and you know it
kind of transferred to more of a store
of value and less of an everyday
payments thing it wasn't until 2017 a
year later that bitcoin cash even forked
off and then that that's what most
people view is that but i was already
living off of dash for a year at that
point because you know and then at that
time i think bitcoin had like 80 market
dominance or anything anyway and so
uh switching to something
less like an altcoin is a term you don't
really hear as much today because it's
just the space is so diverse it's not
all about bitcoin anymore but back then
it was and so
there was there was a lot of challenges
along the way and that's for sure but as
far as have i benefited
i would say absolutely the one thing
it's hard to really see it because it's
my daily life but then i see what other
people do and like oh i got my cards
shut off and this that like all this is
terrible or you know
they just start worrying about
purchasing power or you they have like
an overdraft problem or just there's all
these different things
that happen that you know i have my own
set of you know concerns to do but i
like that i just all the money i have is
all the money i have and that's it it's
it's kind of funny the biggest thing is
the kyc hurdle and that's the thing is
in this whole thing i've stayed away
from like kyc services because you know
otherwise i might as well have a bank
right and how do you do that
well
i have a video series called how to live
on crypto that shows me specifically all
those kinds of things but basically
uh
the process of doing kyc type services
is just it's a huge pain in the butt
like oh well you gotta like do this you
gotta get verified here it's a big delay
whereas
if you just have like have you ever
received some tokens that someone tipped
you on twitter or something like
twitter's full
hey titbot nano
of course why does that not surprise me
uh but anyway
that's the thing is
someone just goes here send you some
stuff and then now you have it you could
like that is such a
it might sound a little dumb trying to
describe this as you know cool that you
just said
but no it's so cool it's so cool imagine
if someone wanted to send you
like a fiat over the same situation
where it's like
oh i want to send you five dollars like
i where's your venmo okay well do you
have one okay but before you do it you
have to go can you get the paperwork and
get verified and just
you know do you have a permanent address
no if you're a nomad sorry you don't
have permanence you can't be banked like
it's it's pretty crazy i was speaking
with the um the ceo of crepe of
a payment app um company and they
they were
he was
ranting about how he has to like rent
office space for like a lot of money
just in order to have bank accounts
because they won't take a post office
box and they won't accept a home address
they're like a home business or anything
you have to rent you know
office space just in order to be have
access to financial services and if for
example you're in between like let's
just say your lease you want to move to
a new place and then the old place um
you know so you're moving between spaces
and then some problem happens in in in
with the new place that you all of a
sudden you can't you might have a
temporary period where you don't have a
either home address if this is your
living situation or a business address
and then all of a sudden oh sorry the
bank you know you can't have a bank
account anymore and so
just the freedom of being able to just
send and receive even you know crappy
little tokens that no one cares about
but it doesn't matter just send receive
just
i'll send you this i'll send you that
i'll send like bits here here grandma
i'm going to send you some over here hey
person across the pond i'll send you
that and it just
the freedom is kind of intoxicating on
that and once you try to go back to the
fiat system in any way or you observe
other people
it's it's a little sad and you kind of
you kind of appreciate what you get out
of it
yeah i think you know
there's so much there to unpack and
for me that was it was kind of the
access to financial services for
everyone which
made me fall in love with cryptocurrency
bitcoin aside i'm not a bitcoin
maximalist i'm i mean i think bitcoin is
the number one in my opinion but you
know i'm open to whatever and i'm
interested to see how things go um but
you know in terms of bringing people on
the financial map it's always been that
which has just warmed my heart mainly
because you see governments and
charities and non-profits and all this
thing for decades trying to solve the
problem of poverty trying to help
supposedly um and it's just a cycle and
nothing is really getting done and now
you have
an opportunity where people can do what
the hell they want with their money i
always look at nigeria as like the most
amazing example i don't know what it is
i'm just i'm genuinely obsessed with the
situation i find it fascinating um in
that they have insane capital controls
they have i think it's a hundred dollars
a month on international payments
how
how how are you supposed to not okay
how do you get out how do you get out of
a situation like that like that that
doesn't just stop you from um you know
building wealth or living day-to-day but
it stops you from creating a business it
stops you from bettering your life like
you can't do anything
um
so
how so in terms of you living unbanked
how does it work how do you get your
groceries how do you do your everyday
things you know do you have
obviously if you need a visa card then
surely you have to do kyc um but you
said you sort of didn't do kyc so you
know you go down to a pub you want to
have we don't have pubs or english
whatever you go to a bar or whatever it
is you want to get a beer
sometimes oh do you all right so you go
get beer in a pub and you want to pay in
with a card how on earth do you do that
yeah so just
i happen to be blessed
well i mean it was a choice but i
blessed nonetheless to live in the
fantastic state of new hampshire which
is kind of crypto ground zero where
uh before gavin andreessen came up here
to some meetups and he got the free talk
live radio show he got them their first
bitcoin i think in 2010. roger ver heard
about bitcoin listening to new hampshire
radio show charlie shrem has been up
here to me as vitalik buterin eric you
know eric voorhees
all these kinds of people are all here
the first bitcoin atm company was
founded right here in new hampshire it's
you know because of that there's a lot
of
uh businesses around here that will take
crypto directly like you know i want to
get my coffee and croissant down at the
la de var in portsmouth yeah i can go do
that if i want to go how do you do that
wait wait how are you doing that though
so uh
there is a company you can give a shout
out to any pay that
they have a crypto point of sale app
that's super easy to use
and
the people behind that
got many although not all of them but
many of the merchants around here to to
to
take cryptocurrency and so
i go down
and i tell them i want to pay in dash
because that's what i have that's the
best easiest spendable money that i have
and i and then they just enter something
turn around the ipad and there's a qr
code i scan it and i pay it and i'm done
and as far as i know
all the businesses around here are
actually holding onto it which is not
something that you could probably see in
other parts of the world most would want
a conversion option which are available
if they want but most places around here
just take and hold that and so they hold
this
they don't turn it into usdt or anything
else
as far as i know i'm not into people's
personal finances as far as i know they
just hold on to it and then spend it
whenever so yeah there's a few
businesses that do that i've been buying
all my organic produce from a farm up
north that has taken
all kinds of cryptocurrencies directly
for many years
and
there's always as far as like the
in-between systems um
there's this fantastic new service
that's come out you know in the last
couple months called dash direct that
basically lets anyone this is because i
had to like spend
years learning how to do this kind of
and having my little world set up in a
way that works for me but
dash direct basically allows you to
spend dash at 155 000 plus merchants in
the us and hopefully soon expanding to
other countries
basically
you walk into a merchant
you
they let's say the total is 23 57 you
enter that into the mat into the app you
hit pay it brings up your dash wallet
you pay for it there and then it it
presents a bar code that then you can
show
and then they scan the barcode and you
pay and this is at like major retailers
whereas you know the places i spend dash
without a an app like this
are minor or like small like local
businesses but if you want to go to say
you know a starbucks or a panera or
something like that or you want to go to
a home depot for a home improvement
project
then that's kind of how you do it and
you
sometimes you can save up to like 15 on
this app and so
i personally believe that this is what's
going to be the last it's going to be
the beginning of
what we fight that mass adoption because
we've tried all kinds of adoption things
and it's just too much of a pain in the
butt for someone to buy cryptocurrency
and then try to figure out how to spend
it so people aren't going to do it but
if you have an app that just has a a
geolocation feature it just says you can
spend it at these five places right next
to you and we'll even like connect to
your maps to show you to go there and
it's a super simple process of doing it
and you can save like let's just say
five eight percent or something on the
purchase doing it you're probably going
to want to do that and
it's just
an even better it's a no kyc service and
non-custodial because there are some
other services that are intermediary
payment things that let you pay with
cryptocurrency like i'm i'm sure paypal
is debuting a thing of their own but for
example something like let's say flexa
which i'm not throwing shade at flexa
because any way you can spin crypto in
the real world is is good but there's a
custodial element to it and there is a
qsd element to it and so yeah that's
that's basically what fills in the rest
of the gaps around those little those
little favorite places i like to go to
to to spend it directly where i know the
owner is hoteling it
up anything else any of these big box
type stores i can use this one app and
that just takes care of just about
everything else
is it available worldwide is it
available in england you know
or is it just in america right now
and they're working hard on getting
canada and then you know then europe and
et cetera but i mean it's a it's a lot
of work to do something i mean you know
155 000 merchants in one go and you know
people are already complaining it's not
my country yet well just wait this way
that's a good thing it's a good thing no
i think that's a great thing if people
are complaining you know i'm shaking my
head you know people are obviously
impressed by the service you know no kyc
and you can go ahead and spend
sounds what sounds like what dreams are
made of um so i have a bit of an
interesting question for you it's a bit
of a side topic um and it's more just
about like relationships and friendships
really um because often people talk
about when they're involved in crypto um
it kind of hinders
their friendships in the real world i'll
explain i don't mean because you're so
head first into on the internet and you
become an absolute recluse i don't mean
that i mean more because i'm a toxic
maximalist and no one likes you anymore
just not even that not even that um
because
mainly because um you start to see the
world in a different kind of a kind of
way and you become awake people often
get very cringed out by this um this
analogy but i really don't care i think
it's fantastic you know you're sort of
awake to the truth of what is going on
and often your political views tend to
fall quite in line with your libertarian
can you leave me alone leave my wallet
alone leave my money alone kind of view
um
so i'm wondering whether you know you
sort of as you went on this journey
because you are fully unbanked you know
so you're you're fully believing in this
you know you're not one for in or one
for out um whether that kind of affected
any of your um personal relationships
and people sort of thought all right i
don't know i don't know this guy anymore
yeah that is not at all been the case
with me but that's only because
i took it the other way around right a
lot of people
normies doing whatever and then they
hear about this cool technology and then
as they start that's like their first
step in the rabbit hole they're like oh
i realize that the money is fake what
else are they lying to us about and then
it just goes down from there whereas i
already came from that direction you
know i'm just passing on the other way
i'm just saying like i already realized
that they were before i knew what what
crypto was i already knew people were i
already knew the government was
inflating away my future i already knew
that there was endless wars being fought
on my dime for
you know no tangible benefit i already
knew
that my rights were being trampled i was
being surveilled all this kind of stuff
i already knew all that coming in so
a lot of the people who i interacted
with
there were you know a lot of the people
who ended up being
ended up you know yes i that there has
been a shift in
community
around me for sure over time but it it
like the crypto is just the latest part
of this this whole journey and i should
also give
a mention because when i moved out to
new hampshire not just because it's a
fantastic place to live and anyone
should visit especially if they're into
crypto but it's because there's this
thing called the free state project
which basically indicates that
everyone who is believes in freedom
again like this whole red-pilled
movement everyone
feeling isolated
can come to one spot just move in one
place it's already it's called to live
free or live free or die is the slogan
of the state like it's been
has freedom in its veins forever
but everyone can come here and just
live free all together and not be alone
anymore and there's a you know reason
why
so many headlines about all this freedom
thing you know is all out of new
hampshire is because of this kind of
thing
so basically
there's a built-in strong community of
people here that are like that so i
would say any crypto person who's
feeling
i don't know a little alienated a little
lonesome now that they they can't relate
to their normal friends anymore because
they started on this road well there's a
there's a whole group of people right
here waiting for you that already
believe the exact same stuff and they're
they're already there with you they're
not gonna look at you weird for they're
they're they already know you know
they're already already awake to all
this stuff
um that's really interesting that it's
this freedom loving kind of safe haven
did you guys ever have a lockdown by any
chance
uh not really there was some
uh as it were
there was a
there were some of these governor's
orders that were basically like well you
should probably wear a mask but
if you have for any any other loophole
or whatever kind of thing you can do so
basically my life has not changed over
the last couple years
and there was some controversy over even
those very late kind of suggestive
things and
the legislature immediately passed i
mean that was one thing that got done
this year restrictions on further
emergency powers of the governor so
nothing even can be approximated like
that in the future and there were a
couple of businesses that got fined for
operating but the government refunded
their fines which i don't think that's
happened anywhere else in the world
right that it's like so wait wait wait
wait
yes so you so wait wait wait you've had
no lockdown
and things have basically been normal
over the last 18 months roughly
yes so there was a a short period of
like a month or so that certain
businesses were
not or not supposed to operate like to
havoc in in-person people for example
and there was a couple that got fined
for not doing that and after that got
changed basically it was a very very
light situation like and even then
that got
the ability to do so has been changed so
that can never happen again and the
businesses affected that were actually
refunded by the government incredible
and so basically yeah we're
we're good to go for the future
and obviously i'm english so i don't
know every single spot on the map
explain to me exactly where new
hampshire is
uh it's basically so if you start
florida and go straight up
yeah and basically right when you hit
canada it's right there oh it's right at
the top on the top yes it's very close
to you know where boston is it's very
close to boston just north of boston
oh my gosh
it's crazy i'll have to come like i have
to check that out i am a freedom loving
person
like i for me freedom
yeah i mean for me freedom above
everything um which takes me on to so
many other exciting topics we could talk
about um but before i go into that i do
wanna i do wanna actually get your
thoughts on cbdc's um i have a
particular passion and dislike towards
them
um i wondered whether whether you
thought
that could potentially uh
let's say replace cryptocurrencies take
down cryptocurrencies
you know do you like them
yeah so
i'm not a fan obviously because
the cb part
is
yeah
right so i'm like i have no use for them
it's not like like a lot of other people
think that oh this is what's going to
start crypto adoption for most people
but like i've already been there for a
half decade like i don't need this stuff
um but so
honestly
like cbdc's are being billed as
something radically different and it's
all it is
is fiat with
more efficient modernized payment rails
that's just it like the entire
and
i always like hesitate to speak too much
on this because
from my knowledge i guess the european
banking system is
significantly better than the american
banking system like the american banking
system is old and antiquated and
terrible and
modernizing that i think is you know
well here's the thing i think it's a
good thing i guess
but
it's still missing the point it's still
just it's still going to be fiat because
the magic of crypto is that you can
independently verify transactions
anywhere are we going to have a
radically transparent
usd
central bank cryptocurrency
is it going to be a radically
transparent blockchain where you can see
all the money the government's stealing
where it's going are they really going
to make that hmm
or also we transparent in one way like
it would go two ways it'll be one way
transparent
yeah and so
can you then can i send my usd coin or
whatever can i just send it to you on
twitter to like a random you know person
on twitter with like an anime character
as their like profile picture and just
thoughtlessly like that and they can
just claim it well no so it's
you know that's the that's been the the
kind of um
stablecoin myth
is a lot of people have been very into
stable coins and sale coins first off
they're paying to figure out mostly and
so the entire reason we got into crypto
was to not have a constantly devalued
money but so we made it make a crypto
that constantly devalues just like the
dollar it's like a little i understand
for traders the only reason like stable
coins really exist if you ask me is
because they managed to get in into a
regulatory loophole where they don't
have to do kyc and these other things
with the fiat system but they are still
kind of fiat but as soon as the if the
government regulated stable coins like
fiat they would just disappear overnight
basically and the same thing with you
know cbdc's is it just
no one's going to be excited about this
stuff unless they offer something new
are they going to provide better
you know freedom of transacting and
fewer you know kyc hookups and you know
or kyc barriers and things i don't think
so because if it what if they do though
what if this the governments say you
know what this crypto stuff is is going
to destroy us so
let's make a
halfway crypto halfway fiat coin that
provides more freedom than fiat but
still people
can have their transactions traced and
stuff like that
i mean i still wouldn't use it but that
would be a net benefit for humanity i
think i mean i i don't think that's
where we need to be we don't need to
care about that stuff though we can
already use you know better things and i
think that you know we talk about you
know the great el salvador experiment
but also other countries and stuff that
are starting to
like once you can just say i don't have
to develop my own cbdc i can just
adopt cryptocurrency is legal tender
and offer certain tax incentives and
stuff for cryptocurrency businesses and
get
this giant industry just all there i
don't i don't really see cbdc's being
like
i think their par their part in the
world the new world will be much smaller
than the central banks issued old
currencies in the old world
i hope so um i think you make it an
important distinction between the
european banking system and the american
banking system because you're absolutely
right only up until about a year ago did
i know that americans couldn't um do
instant bank transfers for free
i know you have like venmo and all these
things that is weird we can um we can
send money to each other um for free
instantly um so you know where i kind of
like woke me up to this stuff there was
a project that i don't know exactly
where it is today but a digital cache
type cryptocurrency based in the
netherlands called golden and they had a
very interesting feature in their wallet
where
first off they had like an auto
converter where you could send this
cryptocurrency to a bitcoin address and
it would in the background for zero fee
or you know or zero confirmation so
instantly convert it to bitcoin and then
send it so it was like you can spend it
anywhere golden's accepted and bitcoin
but you could also put in an e-bond
number into that into like your full
node wallet
and then you send it and
up to a certain amount per week or
whatever it was like no kyc you could
just send euros to someone's bank
account and i just thought that was like
wow you mean you get to just send
someone money and the government doesn't
need your id like
that's really cool i mean obviously a
very small limit like 50 euros a week or
something like that but i still you know
i was like if you want to send five
dollars there's gonna be like a five
dollar fee or something or more and then
it's gonna be you have to do your id so
yeah that's kind of what woke me up
funny that crypto
instructed me on the differences in the
banking systems
yeah it always does it always wakes you
up to the problems and things that you
didn't know but yeah like i said you
know we can just send like 10 pounds um
instantly for free and it's it's super
easy so i'm kind of fascinated by the
fact that you can't um but my my thing
is that cbdc's
will be marketed so well
and i think one of the ways in which
they'll be marketed is we'll be told
that it'll be better for the environment
you know we'll be told that it will help
save the world in terms of poverty
because it can be programmable and you
know we can make it um you know we can
make it work for these certain things
and food benefits and this and that and
it overall
it's just a more efficient enslavement
machine
in that it will be easier to probably do
what they do
as far as
the marketing thing i'm not worried
necessarily about that because one thing
i've learned
over you know it's a hard lesson maybe
that you know i already kind of
understood before i understood better
over time is that the free market is
undefeated you can
tell people what is going to be valued
or what won't be valued and so like for
example whenever you look at the coin
market cap rankings you just like what
what's that one doing up there
how come people are investing in this
and you try to say like people are wrong
people are stupid it's like no
you're stupid not stupid but you're like
you don't understand i don't know
i don't know joel
i don't think no so sorry i am cutting
you off but yes
my problem is my problem is like i think
the majority of the world is very much
asleep and if the last 18 months has
shown us anything it's shown us that and
i do think that people are always
looking for an answer they're looking to
better their lives and i do believe that
this will be marketed as a way to better
their lives you know um you know air
dropping money and lots of exciting new
things that you can do with money i do
think it will be marketed as this shiny
new coin which will help solve poverty
like i genuinely think and i genuinely
believe that people will believe that
and
they'll also be told at the same time
that things like bitcoin are bad for the
environment other cryptocurrencies
they're scams it's anonymous it's
dangerous
and that will deter people away from
that
yeah so
i
sort of disagree that that's where the
threat's coming from i do agree that we
will have threats from cbdc's but it's a
different direction i think that the
threat from cbdc's is
all their old fiat gets turned into new
fiat
and the
tracking and analytics of this new fiat
will be ten times worse than what they
already traced for your payments before
i think that's the real problem where
people get to see every little bit of
money that gets sent they have much
better because you know blockchains are
radically transparent and you know maybe
not to the rest of the public but
they'll be able to do it i think that's
the trojan horse now
that
people don't buy bitcoin because they
heard good things about it over the last
decade or so i mean they've been the
whole you know it's a scam it's a this
it's a you know drug money it's all this
is bad for the environment yet the price
keeps going up because there's a demand
for it people want
to b basically the number one thing that
cryptocurrencies have solved which i
thought it was gonna be number two or
three or four but it turned out to be
number one in the short term is it lets
people
make money people want to make money
like it sounds like the stupidest thing
i'm ever telling you of course everyone
knows you want to make money but that's
why people love dogecoin you can devise
them and then you can get ahead in life
and it
the investing like
if you haven't spoken to ken bozak yet i
believe you should because he's he's i
believe also unbanked on crypto but he's
a completely opposite kind of end of the
spectrum he's into the nft craze and all
that stuff but he got into crypto
because he wanted to invest
when he became he started to see some
gray hairs in his beard he's like i'm an
adult now i need to do adult things what
do adults do well they invest and so he
goes to his bank and says i heard about
this snapchat thing i want to invest in
snapchat and they just laugh at him like
you're not an accredited investor what
are you talking about like you can't get
in on that and so he got really sad like
i tried to be an adult i couldn't and
then he hears oh i can just buy this
bitcoin stuff and i don't need to be a
fancy credit anything and so he does and
it gets in and the simplicity of that
story that i tell endlessly is that
people just want to be able to the
average person can't really invest there
there's always like these barriers
between them and this the average person
can buy basically whatever they want
with their card for example but they
can't invest so that's the number one
value people want to invest and make
more money and they can't so crypto does
that for them and if the cbdc says oh
it's this is it's all dark money over
there and use this one they don't care
because they can't in they can't
buy like
50 you know a hundred pounds worth of e
naira or whatever the hell they have
going on yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
and then like all of a sudden they're
gonna make get it rich off that it's not
gonna work so they're not gonna do that
they're gonna buy bitcoin dogecoin
whatever else they're gonna buy you know
they're going to liquidity farm and
stake a million times over with the d5
and get 200 extra rewards over like
that's what they're going to do and
unless you stop them from doing that
they're i don't see
cbdc's stopping that in the slightest i
just see it as replacing
old fiat with increased surveillance
powers
i definitely agree with you in terms of
um
increased surveillance powers the
the privacy
that we have now the small amount of
privacy that we have left will certainly
be um made even smaller um but yeah no i
i'm totally with you know this we're so
lucky and i talk about this all the time
that we are in a market which is so
brand new um the kind of gains that you
can make right now you certainly won't
be able to make in like 20 years time
unless it's in a new kind of emerging
market um and
you know that kind of takes me back to
the problems with the education system
which i'm so
so passionate about i i absolutely think
it's it's uh you know a waste of time
and energy and um well actually it's not
a waste of time and energy because it's
it's created for a purpose and to be a
certain way and to create certain types
of people um but what upsets me is um
that we we don't know how to invest we
don't know that we need to invest um we
don't know what inflation is and
a lot of the time which i find so
fascinating is people often come to
bitcoin not because they know that
there's a problem
but because they just sort of heard a
bitcoin and it's new and it's calling it
shiny and then you get there and you're
like oh there really is a problem
thank god i have it you know i don't i
wouldn't know what to invest in if it
wasn't for
bitcoin and my time in this industry
yeah also investing is a luxury for a
lot of people
about this and this is where you know
the red pill moment where you hit into
like
people don't oh people are you know i
don't want to be hyperbolic but why not
yeah yeah do it people are people are
debt slaves they
i mean i don't know how bad it is in
other countries but at least in the us
you don't own the house you oh
the bank owns it you you have to make
constant payments or you become homeless
and
you don't own the vehicle you drive you
know there's a loan on that you make a
payment on that you a lot of times buy
stuff with a credit card and you have
that bill to go and you just you're
locked into bills all the time and so
you go to a job that you hate
and you know pay tons of taxes on it and
you
you need to because otherwise your life
falls apart if you don't have that
constant stream going in and where do
you have any money to invest and see it
go up you're stuck in this just you're
stuck not getting ahead in independent
because once you have
money once you have enough money to a
certain degree i mean more money at some
point is just more money but like at
some point it enables you to be free and
once you're free you start questioning
things that your government's telling
you et cetera et cetera and so that's
why only the big fish get to invest in
the legacy systems but then imagine if
you own your vehicle you own your house
you don't
have debt on that although you never own
your
house in the u.s because of property
taxes because you have to pay on money
taxes every year and just owning a thing
but that's a different story but so what
if you own that stuff you don't have
debt all your money is your money you
pay your bills and whatever's left over
you're like well
i'm gonna spend half of this on going
out and getting drinks because i'm a
human being but the other half i'm gonna
go put into something that i think is
going to go up over time and you just
over the course of a few years you now
have an investment that
you know could have done poorly but
could have done fantastically well
especially if you get to you're allowed
to invest in the newest things like
let's say cryptocurrency as opposed to
just like all the you know
whatever people invest in right
and then all of a sudden you can secure
a future and you're not just locked into
the thing now you can tell your boss
that you know what i don't think this is
the right career for me i've done it
enough i'm going to go start my own
podcast i'm going to go start my own
small business i'm going to do whatever
else because i have the investment given
wealth now to be able to do that but you
can't do that if you're locked into the
debt slave system and especially like
i think a lot more people would
seek to get out of that if they knew
they could just
you know
buy some dogecoin or i don't keep
bringing up those guys i hope people
don't buy dogecoin because i don't think
it's going to be going on forever but
it's an example of if people have a goal
they can change their life but if people
are just like well i have to be really
rich to actually invest then they won't
even try to invest at a small
small level it's funny i had a
a i believe is doug scribner who's the
ceo of an atm company a bitcoin atm
company
i interviewed him one time he told me
that
the the lower class
for their investment is lottery tickets
because like every
every you know paycheck they get they
buy a few lottery tickets and yes mostly
for nothing but that's literally how
they invest like they put it towards
chipping away at the percentage chance
that they will have an investment a
retirement money someday and so i mean
that's a little sad to think that that's
an investment thing but it's also a
genius that
even
people with i would say the lower levels
of financial education
understand investment
and they understand that they should be
investing
even if they do it through like maybe
not the most advisable things by like
i'm going to hit it big someday i'm
going to throw they they're still trying
to invest
what if those same people
instead of going to the lottery ticket
machine go to the
you know let's say the the bitcoin atm
and buy whatever like i'm gonna 100 and
people do this by the way they go like
put a hundred dollars and then they get
some put their phone up and they get
some crypto out of it and they just
repeat by
over time and
yeah then all of a sudden oh in a few
years like you you put 500 worth over
the course of a couple years and now all
of a sudden it's like
5 000 or something now you can afford
like a vacation or something for example
now you can go take a nice holiday and
it's you can afford it without yeah so
yeah
i don't know how to conclude that whole
thought you don't need to conclude it
you don't need to conclude it you know
i'm totally with you i think that it's
really just like the land of opportunity
and sometimes i do sound like a broken
record but for me this entire space is
the new 21st century american dream
where we are so early and um also
because it's so unregulated you know how
like a lot of um
industries and a lot of major players
were able to achieve so much back in the
day because there were less regulation
it was true capitalism um and that sort
of reminds me of what we have now and
yeah i'm you know i'm totally with you
like i said before you know i wouldn't
know what to invest in now now i know
like if i do want to start investing in
the stock market now i know um and i'll
you know i'll think about that when the
time comes um but what for me everything
and i think also for you everything sort
of comes down to this idea of freedom
um
so we have like a few minutes left so i
just kind of want to um get your
thoughts on
really just
if you could just summarize why you feel
freedom is so important particularly in
today's day and age you know where we
have lockdowns we have um and i will say
you know coerced
vaccines and and things like this and
you know how bitcoin comes into play and
everything else you know why for you is
freedom um so important
oh yes so i'm going to start with a
hyperbolic statement that's not
it's not like the other ones which is
you know a little bit more true but it's
okay and this is more conceptual right
is
without without
lack of freedom is murder let me explain
that uh
we are born under this earth with a
ticking time bomb of how many days do we
have left before we're gone and i mean
people have all kinds of different real
religious metaphysical opinions and
things like that
but one thing that everyone sort of
agrees on is this is we have this life
and i don't know if we have anything
else like once once we're old and we die
that could be it for what we are as a
person just we're gone right
during this time
you have nothing but endless
possibilities that's the beauty of life
you can do anything you want you just
why like i want to become a karate
champion and you just you can do that
right oh i want to you know become a i
want to you know surf for a living or i
want to invest and have a giant like
boat and just like drive around whatever
your ideas or dreams or whatever you
want to be a scientist i want to invent
a new something i want to go to the moon
i don't care people have all kinds of
things and
freedom
is what lets you do any of these things
and so literally when you are upset that
someone
you know someone dies or gets killed
it's like oh that's that's a tragedy
well we're all ended we're all headed
for that direction
and
the problem is their freedom is cut off
short they run out of options of things
to do in life let's say they're like 24
and they get into a bad vehicle accident
and they they're gone like it's not that
well they were they were always going to
die but because they died so early
there's so many possibilities that are
not there for them anymore
and
in the same way if you can't pursue your
dreams because you're taxed too heavily
or you regulated too heavily or whatever
if you can't live life to your fullest
that is a slow murder it's a slow death
of all the different options and things
you could do with your life you're just
locked in
and you know it's it's just a you know
it's a long torturous existence and so
that's for me what freedom is is the
ability to do just about anything and
the
economics is a great way of measuring i
guess human potential although it's it's
just one metric because you can't
measure
like the human spirit and its
achievements in a objective way because
there's just so much that can be done
but with
it's kind of an interesting thing to see
when there's more freedom like objective
freedom like people can do what they
want
then the economy
takes off like people build more things
people have more food
they have more everything it just and so
that's a sign that like freedom is
synonymous with human flourishing
and we want humanity to flourish don't
we i want myself personally to flourish
i want you to flourish i want everyone
to flourish and so if we're free that's
what happens and so
it's freedom isn't
it
it isn't critically important it's
everything like what do we have if we
don't have freedom everything we do in
life we work hard so we have money so we
have the freedom to just
live in our house we don't or freedom to
go someplace we whatever
that's all we aspire to do is the
freedom to do what we want and basically
the only reason people don't value
freedom
is either they're
using they're using a lack of freedom to
further their own
ends as in they're they're literally
preying on people they're predators
or
they their freedom is too plentiful for
them to see
i'm still here
yeah freedom is only
uh it's only seen with a contrast
so if yes correct yeah it's just like as
i say like freedom freedom is like water
in that
no one's gonna pay a lot of money for
water but it's so crucial to life it's
not until it becomes scarce that you see
the price go up you know pretty basic
economics and so same thing with freedom
people have been able to do just
whatever they want for the most part in
the in the developed world at least
and
this whole like you know well
well just just put this mask on do this
just don't worry about that like
those can like
that won't last very long because once
freedom starts to become more and more
scarce that pumps up the price the price
of freedom is going to go through the
roof pretty soon we're going to see that
and these kinds of poetic speeches of
like oh it's everything and when your
freedom is restricted that's like a slow
murder and all this hyperbolic nonsense
i've been talking about won't be
necessary because the market price of
freedom is going to go through the roof
when it gets restricted people
in 2020 as far as i know over a hundred
thousand people left california and over
a hundred thousand people left new york
because of a lack of freedom and they
moved to freer parts of the united
states you don't think that that's going
to happen even more in the world you
don't think a bunch of australians are
just never going to find a way on little
rafts across the ocean or whatever they
do to get the hell out of that dystopian
hell hole and find a free place you
don't think we're going to see the free
market adjust for this spike in the
price of freedom due to scarcity i think
we will
it's a really interesting way to look at
it i think everything does come back to
supply and demand um i talk a lot about
that in terms of like happiness in life
versus um
like entertainment value and and all
that sort of thing but yeah you're
you're totally right i think
freedom is the most beautiful thing that
we can have as humans and um i think
it's so sad to see that it eroded and to
see people not understand the value in
it and this kind of comes back to what
we're talking about at the beginning of
the conversation when i was sort of
saying you know only experience
can really allow you to understand
and what i would say
is um because it's just like what you
were saying was i think life has been
too easy in the west
you know like we haven't had a real war
you know we haven't had a real war in a
long time not that i want one they're
not at all we won't even i don't think i
don't think we'll have one i don't think
we'll have one in the same sense that we
ever had one you won't have men on the
ground but anyway it's another story for
another time but um you know like you
said people have become um it's like
water so you don't realize the value in
it you don't realize it until until it's
gone like you said you know it's super
it's just there and you can't you can't
see what you have until it's gone and i
think that's the problem i think that's
also why people are so easy to hand it
away and i actually watched um charles
hoskinson hoskinson's um
video uh yesterday yesterday i don't
know if you saw his talk about vaccine
passports and he made a he made a really
important point um
which i think is really hard to um
articulate articulate which is a real
problem that we've had because people
often say what's the problem with a mask
you know what's the problem with the
vaccine what's the problem with this
what's the problem with that it's not so
much
that in and of itself it's more about
once we've set a precedent for mandating
um taking away these certain freedoms
that precedent and that power can then
be
used in a very bad way
in years to come and then he compares it
to blockchain technology and you know
let's say like bitcoin for example and
how you can't change those rules those
rules are set in stone whereas now we
have these emergency powers
lots of things can happen um yeah
i mean that's exactly true but what a
lot of us don't realize is
this isn't where the precedent is set
the precedent was still a long time ago
with
the non-emergency powers think about all
the other things oh you have to you know
you have to have a license to drive a
vehicle well that sounds reasonable
right everyone should you know
you have to get a liquor license because
this is you know potentially dangerous
what's next you have to have a sugar
license because super can kill you
probably faster than you know maybe not
the now call but you know what i'm
saying like it's at what point at what
point do we start to abdicate our
freedom and our responsibility it's not
at where we decided to let people
mandate masks and vaccines that's just
that's just the most obvious and latest
trend but it started a long time ago and
that's when did we
let people say you must use this piece
of paper for money otherwise you're a
criminal if you try to use gold for
example when did we let government tell
us we couldn't trade with whatever we
wanted
you know legal tender laws right like
that
wasn't that a huge red flag wasn't that
a huge precedent set that then they can
just determine what we use
and yeah i mean that's the thing about
you know
obviously cryptocurrency but also just
the freedom movement in general is
it's about it's not a resistance it's a
roll back we're rolling back all the
mistakes of the passage
and bit by bit this was not good let's
make a better version so money
is a great way to start because you know
you start with money
and then what else can you do how can
you
give people more rights how can you you
know all these like antiquated laws and
so like for example i remember a few
years ago there was a law in new
hampshire on the books it was unenforced
for like 100 years that made like
adultery a crime that if you cheated on
your spouse that was like a crime and it
was just on the books because like no
one enforced anymore because the world
moved on but it's still uh one of my
friends saw to it that that law was
repealed and it's you know yeah
it doesn't no one's life changes but
it's still a mistake of the past
roll it back yes that's kind of all
we're trying to do here
so just lastly then um i guess like a in
a one-liner do you think that we will
ever get to a point in society because
society i i'm old enough and smart
enough at this point to know that
sentiment changes
um so do you think we'll get to a point
where sentiment changes and freedom will
be
much more will be truly valued and um
at the forefront
yes absolutely and i think it's i think
it's already happening very fast the
thing is
uh
what people don't necessarily understand
about freedom
people a lot of people who are the
biggest freedom advocates don't
understand necessarily that the freedom
is also the freedom to not be free
and a lot of people
will
choose
to live in places with different
jurisdictions that inhibit their freedom
because they kind of like that i think
they like that it just oh they do
there is a choice
for the people who care about freedom to
go there then what happens over time is
the after effects of freedom like the
whole idea of america like this is not a
special country this is just there's so
many beautiful countries all across the
world the only reason why anyone cared
about america to begin with was because
it had a better freedom climate than
anywhere else and then people saw it
people didn't think oh i like the idea
of freedom i'm going to move there they
just saw stuff was going great here and
then they wanted to move and it's the
same thing about like there's hellhole
places in the us that most people are
leaving right and they're going to other
better areas that have a freer
jurisdiction
just not because oh conceptually freedom
but because they're like
where i live has a ton of crime
it's extremely expensive i can't go
outside without covering my face i can't
go to my restaurant i can't i this is
the better i'm going to go to the better
place and so basically about is is
freedom in our future absolutely for the
people who choose it and over time the
free market right in a competitive
environment between unfree and free
the best solution always wins and the
freer places will rise to the top and
then the people who chose the unfree
places will start to change their mind
and they won't know that it's because of
freedom but it will be because of
freedom
absolutely it's the same as people
leaving california to go down to texas
to vote democrats they don't know why
they're leaving they don't know why they
they don't like california but they'll
wait for the same rules which ruined it
anyway
um joel it's been such a pleasure um
this was so last minute um but it's been
so interesting talking to you so i want
to thank you so much for coming on
yeah no problem it's been a distinct
pleasure as always absolutely and guys
thank you so much for watching don't
forget to tune in next week for another
amazing discussion most probably around
freedom and bitcoin all right have a
great day bye
[Applause]
[Music]